David Cameron needs to focus - and say
look you may not like me very much Tory
party but do you like do you dislike me
more than you dislike Ed Miliband over
this time next year one of the two of us
is going to be in power so I've been
really struck this week how many Tories
have spoken to who actually if given
that choice was good for Miliband rather
than Cameron who want him gone so much
now and badou so not out of a sense of
personal malice they've just decided
that the Conservative Party would be
better off without Cameron that if he
stays there he will kill the party the
only way to save the party is to get rid
of him now a defeat is not inevitable
for the Tories but it will be if enough
Tories believe that it is the real name
for the Tory party is but in this mood
but the party conference we're talking
exactly volatile for them um turns into
a beauty contest we look at you know
Teresa may versus Boris Johnson for the
leadership for you oh I quite like Sajid
Javid is a dark horse you know
the 2010 take candidate coming up on the
inside all that kind of stuff because I
mean there's as Fraser says the more
rhetoric party thinks about defeat and
the leadership contests that follows the
more it makes that defeat lightly right
now the question the Tory party faces is
this I mean do the left and the right
want to co-exist or do there's one one
to expunge the other no Liam Fox when he
was standing for leader he's a good
phrase which it was that in British
politics we have internal coalition's to
avoid external coalition's in other
words he was saying yes I'm from the
right to the party but I will try to
coexist with my colleagues in the left
because we need to keep us party
together
you don't hear language like that right
now you hear left and right saying the
other lots have lost as the election
this time we got rid of them this is one
Tory MP said to me there is a kind of
civil war mentality in the Tory party
right now where we're hurting the other
side it is actually more important than
advancing your own goals but I think
that Cameron's great hope is here is the
fact that Ed Miliband is a radical
politician and he is going to seek a
mandate to change Britain
I mean the toy party at some point will
wake up and realize that the bits of the
factory settlement that the party holds
incredibly dear will go
if Miliband becomes PM over the decades
the Tory party is proven very good at
two things one is UT and winning
elections the other is suicide now it
just depends is the Tory party going
through one of its suicidal phases has
it decided that unity is just too much
and does it just want to revise this
kind of cycle of reprisals which has
been going much pretty doing pretty much
since Thatcher was deposed from power
and I think the problem is they're not
listening hard enough to Ed Miliband
they don't think he's serious I mean I
do I think in Miliband is a man of
unusual principle and originality I also
think he's entirely wrong is this party
King bull of throwing power away I'm
afraid it is yes